all right let's get into audience
questions for the week very important
political issues
and many other things to talk about
really important issue right off the top
relates to foreign policy i got a bunch
of questions that were basically some
version of this
why do trump supporters suddenly
not want us to leave afghanistan which
joe biden is doing
given that it was donald trump's idea
do you do you you really don't know the
answer to this one i mean listen guys
the
they liked it when it was trump's idea
but not when it's joe biden doing it
uh look at the iraq war george w
bush in 2003 uh says doesn't actually
say but
says even though it was not iraq that
attacked us on 911
george w bush says we're going to go
into iraq and whether it was trying to
finish
what his father george h.w bush left
undone
or a cynical political ploy because
uh saddam hussein was widely seen uh and
accurately so is not a particularly good
guy whatever the reason was
at that time if you questioned what the
hell are we doing in iraq
you were called unpatriotic you were
accused of not supporting the troops etc
in comes trump and trump says hey you
know what i was against going into iraq
that was a disaster
i'm going to fix the republican party
i'm not going to do stupid stuff like
george w bush and
by and large his followers in 2015 2016
fell for that which 13 years before
would have been unthinkable
in most republican circles except for
some like more extreme
traditional libertarian circles
that's what democrats have been saying
all along but when trump says it
they believe it and it's the exact same
thing with afghanistan
trump said we're getting the hell out of
afghanistan
and i'll talk about whether that makes
sense in a moment but hint it does
um and then when joe biden came into
office and at the time
republicans sort of said they liked it i
mean i guess
joe biden came in and said listen i'm
not saying we're not getting out of
afghanistan but trump is such a buffoon
my word's not his i'm pausing everything
trump was doing to review it
and then i'll make a decision and joe
biden made the decision
he's going to keep going with the
afghanistan withdrawal and
it will the announcement was instead of
being in may which was trump's idea
it will be by september 11th a delay of
about four months
even though it appears to be happening
more quickly and will be done roughly
similarly to when donald trump's was
it's basically the same thing that joe
biden's doing is what donald trump is
doing but now
all these republicans and trumpets are
saying whoa hold on a second
joe biden has no plan for how to get out
did trump he just said we're leaving joe
biden is getting out in a way that could
leave a vacuum
that's always been the concern what's
new about that
so they're just pathetic political
statements
i wouldn't pay too much attention to
them for the most part
foreign policy in this way
i don't believe is really even going to
play a role in 2024 unless something
dramatically changes
um so it's it's very transparent
cynicism uh and the analysis is super
simple
they liked it when trump was doing it
when biden's doing it
by definition it's not good because
biden as they see it
is incompetent and won't do it the right
way
now in terms of getting out it's just
time
and i've said for a long time when you
break something you own it then you got
to fix it
and so when uh this applied to
afghanistan and this applied to iraq
when you go in
as the united states did and wreak havoc
and cause chaos
without even evaluating whether your
motivations were good or bad like i'm
not even including that in this
conversation as relevant as it is
if you cause the chaos you have some
responsibility to fix it
and um the question then becomes
how many years how many administrations
worth and
at a certain point particularly when you
realize just staying won't fix it
you have to say this is as far as the
responsibility goes and it's time to get
out so
are we responsible for the state of
affairs currently in afghanistan as well
as in iraq of course
would our responsibility dictate that we
stay
even if we only continue to make it
worse or at least not better i think
there's a limit to it and i think that
limit has been reached 20 years
so it is time to get out things may go
downhill
as a result and that is going to have to
be dealt with but at a certain point the
responsibility has to stop so the trump
supporters now saying biden shouldn't
get out but trump was and i liked it
then
but i don't like it now don't pay
attention to them but there are real
serious questions about the limits of
american responsibility
when we get into these quagmires abroad
and that's a much bigger topic for a
different day
one of our sponsors is privacy.com
they're giving you five dollars when you
sign up for their completely
free service at privacy.com slash pacman
i've been using privacy for a little
over a year now you've heard me talk
about it before
it's a lifesaver and here's how it works
takes just a couple of minutes to set up
anytime you buy something
online or on the phone instead of
actually using your real credit card
number the privacy app
and the browser plugin let you give each
company
a randomized virtual credit card number
that you create
out of thin air it'll even autofill the
card number with one click
and the payment is taken out of your
checking account
without the merchant ever knowing your
real information so this allows you to
keep
your banking information secure but also
to take control of your finances you can
create
up to 12 of these virtual credit cards a
month you can set
spending limits you can freeze them you
can delete them anytime you want so when
you do this
it means you're not going to be charged
when you don't want to be
because you can destroy the virtual card
number
right after using it which for instance
i love using free trials because i know
i won't be charged when the trial is
over
if i use a virtual credit card number
you're keeping your identity private
by not telling companies who you are
you're keeping your bank or
credit card info protected against data
breaches and identity theft
and it's free and like i said you'll get
five dollars to spend when you sign up
at privacy.com slash pacman